si on cherche à réduire la dette ce que
propose par exemple monsieur bruno le
maire donc si on cherche à réduire la
dette
on sera amené à couper dans ses
investissements en infrastructures par
exemple les investissements dans la
santé la question des hôpitaux mais
aussi la question des transports publics
et ça provoquera à nouveau une véritable
crise c'est cela qui constitue en
réalité la véritable je dirais bombe à
retardement à l'intérieur de l'économie
française 118 % du pib c'est le niveau
que devrait atteindre la dette publique
à la fin de l'année selon bercy
l'effet de la poursuite du fameux quoi
qu'il en coûte en plein reconfirme ans
mais que faire de la partie covit de
cette dette dont le gouvernement nous
assure qu'elle devra être remboursé pour
y arriver les français vont-ils devoir
faire des sacrifices ou y at il d'autres
solutions pour neutraliser cette dette
voire l'annuler c'est l'objet de
desdites aux échos ce soir bonsoir
j'accepte et alors on va aller droit au
but êtes vous partisan d'une et d'une
annulation de la dette comme i do est ce
que vous considérez qu'une dette doit
toujours être remboursés pour faire
c'est fini effectivement si on pose la
question dans ces termes il est sûr
qu'on n'aura pas de bonne réponse alors
d'abord il faut dire une chose c'est que
les annulations de dettes sont des
choses en réalité très fréquentes
on avait par exemple et il ya de cela
maintenant quelques années les
annulations en club de paris où il
s'agissait de la dette publique
annulée par des créanciers publics ou en
club de londres
ladd et privé cette fois ci par rapport
aux pays en voie de développement
et puis il faut quand même rappeler que
depuis le début du 19e siècle
il ya eu énormément de pays qui ont fait
défaut et qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
défaut si ce n'est qu'une annulation de
tout ou partie de la dette donc placé si
vous voulez c'est quelque chose d'assez
commun d'assez courant mais en réalité
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas ça le problème
essentiel
le problème essentiel tout d'abord c'est
le poids des intérêts dans le budget et
puis c'est la question de savoir comment
on finance de nouveaux investissements
car c'est ça
qui va être réellement la question qui
va se poser à la fin de la crise
sanitaire
alors jacques tout d'abord voyons déjà
où on est la dette publique
si vous voulez comme vous l'avez dit la
dette publique elle atteint fin elle va
atteindre à la fin de cette année 118 %
du pib
c'est ce qu'a annoncé bercy en dépit
d'une croissance d'environ 5% après
qu'est ce qu'on voit eh bien on voit par
exemple sur ce graphique que la dette a
été relativement maîtrisée jusqu'en 2007
à partir de là crise de 2008 2009
elle a commencé à monter assez
régulièrement et qu'elle a surtout
éclaté avec la crise qu vide et on
constate d'ailleurs que c'est à peu près
la même situation avec d'autres pays
comme l'espagne ou comme l'italie qui
est aujourd'hui à 160% alors en réalité
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui le la part
importante de la dette c'est évidemment
la dette qui est liée à la copie de 19
alors qui vit accroissement de la dette
ne dit-il pas alourdissement de la
charge des intérêts effectivement on
pourrait le penser mais en fait que les
taux d'intérêts à court et à moyen terme
sont aujourd'hui négatif grâce à
l'action de la banque centrale
européenne eh bien on voit que les taux
d'intérêts plus avenant là la charge des
intérêts dans le budget ne cesse de
baisser
on était grosso modo à 52 milliards
d'euros en 2011-2012
on était tombé déjà en 2015 autour de 45
milliards d'euros
et on est en 2020 un petit peu au dessus
de 30 milliards d'euros et cela avec un
montant global de dette qui a beaucoup
augmenté
donc oui effectivement la question du
remboursement ou en tous les cas de
payer des intérêts ne se pose pas dans
l'immédiat alors mis si ces taux ne se
remettaient à augmenter ça veut dire que
ce serait une catastrophe à sabri ah ça
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est fanny
ça serait une catastrophe pour les pays
du sud 1
pour l'italie mais aussi pour la france
et pour l'espagne et c'est d'ailleurs
cette perspective qui aujourd'hui
inquiète le ministre des finances à
monsieur bruno le maire et c'est pour ça
que monsieur bruno le maire voudrait
absolument que l'on commence à faire
baisser le poids de la dette au risque
et au prix de pousser la france à
nouveau dans une situation de récession
donc ceux qui estiment que sa dette est
largement conjoncturelle et qu'elle
pourrait être en partie annulés par la
bce ont ils raison oui en un sens oui et
si vous voulez parce que il est clair
que une partie de cette dette en
particulier justement la dette qui est
liée à la coville 19 elle est d'ores et
déjà détenues par la banque centrale
européenne et donc on comprend pourquoi
toute une série d'économies dont mon
collègue piketty propose justement soit
d'annuler cette partie de la dette soit
de la transformer en des perpétuelles
alors naturellement ce type de
proposition rencontre une opposition
absolument ferme à la fois de la part du
ministre français des finances donc de
monsieur bruno le maire mais aussi de
madame christine lagarde la patronne de
la banque centrale européenne même si il
faut le dire que madame lagarde est un
peu plus ouverte en ce qui concerne la
proposition de transformer une partie de
cette dette en dette perpétuelle ou en
télé car comme on le dit de la cantonner
pour plusieurs années alors justement
jeanne d'où provient cette dérive du
déficit alors la question essentielle et
ça vous l'avait bien dit c'est justement
la question des déficits alors en
réalité quand on regarde l'évolution des
structures du jetair on voit que bon les
les finances locales ont tenu leur
budget bon an mal an avec des années où
il était en déficit d'autres années où
elle était en excédent qu'il n'ya pas
réellement de problème sur la sécurité
sociale parce qu'on voit que les comptes
de la sécurité sociale étaient revenus
hu en excédent à partir de 2016 2017
par contre il ya un véritable problème
au niveau évidemment des administrations
publiques de l'état central et pourquoi
a t'on ce problème et bien parce que là
on touche à la question justement un
désinvestissement des frais de
fonctionnement est aussi bien entendu
des transferts sociaux
alors on voit bien que c'est là que se
trouve le problème parce que si on
cherche à réduire la dette
ce que propose par exemple monsieur
bruno le maire donc si on cherche à
réduire la dette
on sera amené à couper dans ses
investissements en infrastructures par
exemple les investissements dans la
santé la question des hôpitaux mais
aussi la question des transports publics
et ça provoquera à nouveau une véritable
crise c'est cela qui constitue en
réalité la véritable je dirais bombe à
retardement à l'intérieur de l'économie
française mais alors jacques que faire
alors
il ya en fait deux possibilités il ya
deux solutions la première solution
ça serait que l'état dans sa
présentation du budget s'est pas de
manière très nette
ce qui relève des investissements en
infrastructures de ce qui relève des
frais de fonctionnement et des frais de
transfert liées justement à la
répartition sociale
bon ça serait déjà une première chose et
puis la deuxième chose qu'il faudrait
faire ça serait de revenir en réalité à
la situation dans laquelle on était dans
les années 50 60 et au début des années
soixante dix
autrement dit mme de faire en sorte que
les dépenses en infrastructures soient
payés par des avances faites par la
banque de france directement au trésor
ce qu'on appelait le circuit du trésor
public
c'est quand même ainsi que la france a
financé
si on veut sa reconstruction dans les
années 50 et 60
et ça constituerait la possibilité pour
nous de sortir de la crise économique
alors j'ai ce que vous
en substance et quand sans précédent sur
la question de la dette
finalement on se trompe de sujet oui
tout à fait tout à fait et il est
frappant de voir comment que ce soit les
économistes qui justement se concentre
sur cette annulation de la dette
e ou comme le ministre de l'économie
monsieur bruno le maire veut en rien et
ils font l'un et l'autre les uns et les
autres ils font la même erreur parce que
en réalité le problème ce n'est pas la
question de la dette ce n'est pas la
question de savoir comment on va digérer
ce surcroît de dette qui a été lié à la
crise sanitaire
la véritable question c'est la question
de savoir comment nous allons financer
les investissements qui sont aujourd'hui
absolument nécessaire pour que la france
sorte de la crise une crise dans
laquelle elle s'enfonce avec évidemment
la crise sanitaire mais qui avait
commencé avant cette crise sanitaire et
qui est surtout marquée par un décalage
de plus en plus important avec que ce
soit en asie où que ce soit les états
unis voire l'allemagne c'est ça qui est
en réalité le principal problème et
c'est là où on voit la nécessité de
penser de manière peut être tout à fait
différent la question de la dette